voilà vincent cassel qui est le fils de
jean pierre cassel et qui danse qui joue
pardon dans ce film de mathieu kassovitz
nicole quand une angoisse je crois que
mathieu kassovitz est à vos côtés
oui il est là avec ces trois acteurs
bien tout
oui absolument alors je voulais d'abord
vous féliciter mathieu kassovitz parce
que c'est vrai que c'est une mise en
scène très très forte très solide très
original str mais oui c'est un vrai coup
de poing ce film ça c'est vrai et que
vous nous présentiez à l'orgue ou trois
acteurs qui sont ici et qui sont les
trois héros de ce film une façon qu'à
celle qui est dans le flou et qui joue
un rôle de finn ski et qui est celui qui
a la haine
saïd taghmaoui qui joue le rôle de celle
qui dans le film est celui qui a la
haine et hubert koundé qui joueront le
hubert qui est celui dans ce schéma la
haine qu'ils n'ont chacun mais de façon
un peu différente indigents niveau alors
vous êtes parti d'un fait divers réel
qui est donc une bavure policière et la
mort d'un jeune garçon
quelle est la part de réalité de fiction
dans ce film tout est de la fiction non
vous n'êtes pas parti de l'ars apps etc
ça nous a aidé pour l'inspiration de
base oui pour le moteur mais pas du tout
pour l'histoire sinon tout est fiction
tout est inventé mais
c'est vrai puisque ont inventé donc
c'est la journée de deux trois jeunes et
leur journée de trois jeunes qui vivent
dans le quartier des muguets et c'est le
lendemain matin d'une émeute un garçon a
été blessé
et les lieux des émeutes dans la nuit on
retrouve lendemain matin ces trois
personnages qui vont passer la journée
avec en poche une arme ce que vince a
dans sa poche une arme un flingue dans
les flics qui l'a perdue prône la
fermeté avec on sait pas bien ce que ce
que des extraits on sait pas ce qu'on va
faire
mathieu kassovitz vous nous aviez dit en
prêtant venant présenter le film ici à
paris que vous souhaitiez secoué en
quelque sorte le festival de cannes
c'est réussi non on n'est pas là pour
secouer quoi que ce soit ou ça marche
tant mieux ça marche pas c'était pas si
on n'est pas là pour ça on est venu
parce que on a créé du cinéma on a fait
un film de cinéma
on parle d'un sujet qui est grave mais
on est venu là où plus rien n'est grave
pour pour défendre le film plus
longtemps que fini qu'en tant que qu'en
tant que sujet mal parce que ici c'est
pas ici qu'on pourra le défendre et on a
pas on n'est pas là pour faire pour
remuer quoi que ce soit mais j'aimerais
j'aimerais savoir ce que pour vous trois
tâches à 15 que représente cette
aventure de ce film cette expérience
plutôt de sept films
maintenant ce qui me concerne c'était ça
a été la première fois que je me
retrouvais impliqués à son prochain film
où j'ai compris que ça voulait dire du
travail est avantagé
posez l'acteur est en cours on sait bien
travaillé de bon moi c'est pareil les
espèces de chaleur humaine qui s'est
dégagée pendant tout le tournage est là
et elouan la poussée de truc à fond là
toujours travailler plus sans jamais se
complaire et c'était une belle aventure
moi ce qui m'intéresse heures réellement
pas comme comme tous les 3gs j'ai
beaucoup appris humainement
en besoin en faisant ce film lui
maintenant ce qui sera intéressant c'est
que c'est que outre ce prix de la mise
en scène ce que le public à y voir le
cul parce que c'est lui le réel roi quoi
mathieu kassovitz voulez savoir ce que
vous avez ressenti tout à l'heure on
vous a vu à l'image quand vous avez reçu
cette récompense c'est votre deuxième
long métrage de le disais vous n'avait
que 27 ans j'imagine que c'était une
immense satisfaction intérieure en tout
cas c'est pas du tout ce que j'ai
ressenti j'ai pas traîné à bon non c'est
non mais c'est impressionnant va oui
c'est vrai ça c'est vrai qu'on pas vous
en dire plus je regardais la cassette
pour voir comment des p je vous remercie
infiniment je vous propose nicole devoir
maintenant un extrait de la palme d'or
nous on a vu tout à l'heure emir
kusturica qui la recevait on filme donc
underground qui raconte je vous le
disais 50 ans de la vie en yougoslavie
regardez c'est un film qui dure plus de
trois heures
inférieur
oui
[Musique]
et
ne-yo
[Musique]
je ne
nicole je crois qu'à emir kusturica
devient deviennent arrivé à vos côtés
oui il est là il va oui ça n'est pas
franchement ça n'est pas franchement une
surprise
il avait la faveur des pronostics
absolument c'était le favori parce que
nous avons tous adoré ici ce film très
baroque plein d'imagination et qui
relate tout de même des faits très
important ce sont c'est un groupe de 20
personnes qui sont dans une cave pendant
la guerre de la dernière guerre mondiale
et qu'il reste vingt ans car l'un d'eux
lé maintien ici pour faire du trafic
d'armes
alors c'est une expérience assez
étonnant vous avez la traduction
j'espère oui voilà alors de cette
histoire là que vouliez-vous faire
ressortir
alors je voulais alors les jours que
j'ai passés hors de mon pays j'ai tant
soulevé qu'il a fallu que je fasse ce
film mais il ne fallait pas que ce soit
comme le font les médias sous de très
superficielle j'avais le sentiment
il fallait que le paraphe il voulait
monde les gens veuillent show qui se
passait vraiment et que je vous fasse
comprendre ce qu'était la vraie source
de nos problèmes
oui d'ailleurs aujourd'hui nous avons
une actualité sur la yougoslavie donc
c'était c'était vraiment le besoin de
faire ressentir exactement ce qu'est
actuellement les gosses la vie à travers
cette une espace de métaphores et ce qui
est extraordinaire c'est que ces gens là
sont toujours liés il continue à rire en
tout cas dans votre film
les rires sont excessives tout est
excessif dans votre film
pourtant dès aujourd'hui les gens sont
éduqués pour la télévision
des hommes tous les jours il voit des
gens que l'on tue même des gauchers your
side
il avait l'habitude de voir des genres
et mon style chef de le faire voir ce qu
il faut d espagne et ce sont des gens
qui suivent leur histoire et qui de
temps en temps son très long les boues
nous sommes nous sommes pris par le
temps jeu